for daily wire targets sales have
declined after backlash to its pride
month collection earlier this year the
company announced on Wednesday targets
quarterly sales sent for the first time
in six years falling 5.4 percent in the
second quarter which ended July 29th
compared to the same period last year
according to the company's second
quarter earnings report online sales
fell nearly twice as much 10.5 percent
Target said the company also said the
number of transactions and the average
dollar amount of a transaction fell this
past quarter targets total revenue of
24.8 billion was 4.9 percent lower than
last year the minneapolis-based retail
Behemoth said that because of recent
sales Trends it has lowered its overall
sales and profit expectations for the
whole year
of course as you know back in May Target
face backlash over its Pride collection
which included a kids swimsuit with a
tag reading thoughtfully fit on multiple
body types and gender Expressions
um and we know about the satanic stuff
and the pronoun stuff and all the rest
of it
um
Target spokeswoman Kayla uh Castaneda
said quote in late May given these
volatile circumstances we're making
adjustments to our plans including
removing items that have been at the
center of the most significant
confrontational Behavior so I was back
in May
um
but on Wednesday the target Chief growth
officer Christina hennington
said that uh the sales were impacted by
the quote strong reaction to this year's
Pride assortment and she says the
reaction is a signal for us to pause
adapt and learn
so this is uh should be needless to say
a major victory
and you know having Target
I mean there's the the sales hit they
took but also a statement like that from
a company like Target
um
only only they're saying it because of
backlash from our side I mean that this
is that rarely happens so almost every
case if you've got a company like Target
and they issue a statement saying
um it's time for us as a company to
adapt and learn and educate ourselves
in almost every case if you even if you
have no contacts you don't know what
they're talking about
and you hear a company put out a
statement like that you just assume that
oh well the left must be mad at them for
something
if they're promising to adapt and learn
and educate
but in this case no they're saying it's
because of us
is because we said we don't want this
disgusting stuff right in front of our
kids
then now Target is saying well we need
to learn it's a learning moment for us
um that represents them bending the knee
to us
for a change
and you can always point out well then I
think they still have the pride stuff
they didn't even get rid of it at the
time they moved it to the back of the
store
you know do I think that come pride
month next year that they're going to
have no Pride merchandise at all that
there's going to be no rainbows no of
course they're still gonna have some of
that stuff
but they're going to Tamp it down
considerably
and they're going to do it because we
demanded it
that is a victory
before giving our dog rough greens he
was so sad and lazy he wasn't getting
the nutrients he needed now he's happier
and healthier my team keeps joking that
we need to sign it up for one of those
speed course dog shows you know it's we
stand around joking about my dog talk
about my dog all the time so that joke
was made about my dog and I'm always
talking about my dog anyway naturopathic
Dr Dennis black the founder of rough
greens is focused on improving the
health of every dog in America little
did I know before I got rough greens dog
food is dead food everybody knows the
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens boost your dogs food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough grains on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough grants
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels so much more
we are what we eat and that goes for
dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis black is
a so confident rough greens will improve
your dog's health he's offering my
listeners a free jump start trial bag so
you and your dog can try it a free
jumpstart trial bag could be at your
door in just a few business days go to
roughgreens.com Matt or call 844 rough
700 that's ruffgreens.com or call 844
rough 700 today
now Target is not Bud Light uh in that
they're not going to be totally
destroyed by this like Bud Light is in
shambles they're just in route the brand
is in Ruins permanently
um probably not the case for Target
uh but they've lost millions and
millions of dollars
and that matters
it really matters and I think the damage
for them uh is is
it will also be long term if not
permanent
I mean I can tell you that I'm never
going back to Target
my family's not going back there and I
know plenty of people who say the same
and and um
the problem for Target is that like with
so many of these companies and products
you know you use the product or you go
to this this particular store
uh or this brand or whatever and and you
do it reflexively because it's just like
part of your routine so for a lot of
people
and this was always the big hurdle when
all this first happened with Target and
I remember I was talking about the
boycott of course pushing for the
boycott and I said at the time the big
hurdle we have to get over here is that
like this is just a part of people's
lives part of their routine oh you go to
Target three times a week
and to get people to develop different
habits to get consumers to develop
different habits in response to your
boycott campaigns very very difficult
but we succeeded
and a lot of people have developed and
so you spend a couple you know you think
well I got a Target three times a week
it's right down the road for me uh it's
gonna be a big hassle if I cut Target up
well then you do it and you realize okay
yeah I don't really need to go to Target
there's like a million other places I
could go I don't need to go to Target
and you spent a couple months not going
to Target and then it's like why would I
start going now
I obviously I'm surviving just fine
and it hasn't even been a great
inconvenience it turns out
so that that's a big problem for Target
now is um that
it's not just the boycott anymore it's
that consumers have you know a sizable
chunk of consumers have developed
different consumer habits
to get a round Target
and
why would they stop now
um
and all of this really matters and it
matters because
no matter what anyone tells you
when it comes down to it the old cliche
still applies you know Money Talks
and that they are these businesses they
want to make money they need to make
money okay this is not a big Revelation
the the woke virtuous virtue signaling
The Pride stuff
why do they do that well they do it for
ideological reasons they do it
because the people running these
companies you know they they really do
hate their conservative customers and
they hate conservatives in general and
so there's some real
uh feeling behind it on their part and
some real contempt and yeah that's part
of it they do it for their ESG scores
they do it for different reasons but
ultimately
it always boils down to money
it does you know and it's it's it's
marketing
that's what it is
all these other things are contributing
factors
but for for so many years the company
has really leaned into uh pride and
rainbows and gay whatever and all that
and they they really did that because
they figured this is great marketing and
we make money off of it
all the other stuff those are just
that that's all uh peripheral
so
what these companies are now discovering
is that uh it's not that simple
it's not that simple I mean at a minimum
it's not that simple
is this not necessary this is not going
to be a simple thing where you just
throw the rainbows all over the place
and um
it's a it's a good good marketing
opportunity for you and all that and
it's not going to be that way
like there's a real cost when you decide
to go that direction as a brand and
there's a real risk involved
that's the message that these companies
and these brands have now absorbed and
they're now they're looking at Target
and they're looking at Bud Light and
they're realizing that
okay if we do this there's a risk like
we stand to lose millions of dollars
does that mean they're all going to stop
doing it no
but they understand that there is a risk
and uh that is a
significant victory
for the right in the culture War I mean
it actually is hard to overstate what a
victory it actually is
um
and there's no reason to relent no
reason to let up we absolutely should
not if you'd like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed